hello everyone and welcome back to the
2019 FIBA World Cup it's a game for of
the classical match the England versus
team another job of and as you know the
first game they played ended in a draw
then didn't want a very nice game with
the white pieces then their Java
retaliated with the white pieces and now
again it's if either of them wins this
game it's game over for the player who
lost but if if it's a row for example
then we go into the rabbit Ibrox so
without further ado let's check out what
happened here as being again has the
white pieces so linked with the white
pieces opened with c4 again he goes for
his English opening we have Knight to f6
Knight that's not a knight Knight to c3
and now II five with Knight to f3 and
Knight to c6 with g3 biting preparing to
fianchetto the light-square bishop and
now d5 as it has been prepared with C
captures on d5 Knight captures on d5 and
Bishop the g2 so this is all very
standard stuff Bishop to c5 better job
of and here the main movies castles
everyone castles here that's the what
you play in 2019 in this position but
here Dean goes for Knight captures on e5
and it's a it's an extremely rare move
and seemingly it is what's being
prepared for this game and okay we have
Knight captures and c3 Bishop captures
and cc6 with Czech beat captures on c6
and now be captures and c3 you don't
have time for Knight captures here is
sort of a to grab the pawn back and in
trade Queens because Queen f6 just
threatens a tomato or losing the Queen
so here our Dean would just be lost so
just be captures on c3 and now comes
Queen to d5 going after dings rook and
nicely centralizing the Queen while also
attacking the knight so to print both
threats of course you will bring the
knight back with nice to f3 and now
comes
Bishop to h3 of course preventing them
from castling and there is this position
has been reached before but it's not you
know eat chairs that it was reached it
was in 1999 between a 2100 player and an
untitled player so this is the
the game that didn't decided to revive
in the game wife continued with rook to
g1 sort of preventing Bishop the g2 to
come with an attack against rook in the
night but here ding plays Queen to b3
and it is as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so very exciting
stuff and of course if the Queen is
captured ending just to get the fix this
pawn structure he opens up da file for
his rook and if not it's a double who
has to make a move and without much
thinking about it a Java goes Bishop to
g2 so also I forgot to mention in that
game 2100 player versus the untitled
prayer untitled player actually won this
foot black so this is a very tricky to
play with white this is what being
decided to do here so Bishop to g2 and
ding it now has to decide and it was
very interesting that being started
thinking here so ding played Queen b3 a
new move in the position and when our
gerbil replied here ding started wasting
time he spent like 15 minutes on his
next move which was very interesting as
he was supposed to be the one surprising
or a job and of course ding had the
bishop to g2 in his home analysis but
it's it's hot hard to say what he was
considering here but we often get this
for example if you remember when we were
covering the botanique versus stall
roaches Championship match in 1960 then
but when he played the position he
prepared at home but he still wasted
like 15 20 minutes on a move that he
already knew he was gonna play so maybe
it was something similar here but
basically being here is deciding whether
he wants to capture he doesn't want a
lot of course special characters and
then Queen recaptures on f3 or the very
tricky C form which keeps the Queen on
the board and creates creates a lot of
mess so what would happen here obviously
bring the Queen back and now rook the g1
you want to get your rook away from
there but now look the b8 by black and
here it's a very tricky position you
could decide to just grab the bishop and
give up your queen for a rook and the
bishop but most likely you you will not
do that so you will move the Queen and
then you'll get bushel characters Queen
captures on f3 and now Queen to d4
we'll be deadly bye black so not not
something you want to do probably it was
analyzed even over the board but yeah
how hard you saved the rook you don't
you really don't you have to go for
Queen captures and c6 check King here
and now trade Queens but it does not
help White Queen captures he captures
and now Bishop the d4 again traps the
rook as the b1 square is covered by the
rook so c4 or a very complicated move
but probably being headed analyzed at
home and he was just checking making
sure that he wants to grab the Queen
here probably already analyzing the
endgame but okay Queen captures on d5
biding in the end see captors on d5 and
now rook to g1 attacking the bishop the
ship characters on f3 and now he
captures on f3 and here it was a Rajah
who started thinking he took some 15
minutes to decide what to play here so
feel free to pause the video and decide
for yourselves how would you continue
this game with with black might be
interesting to try that so for those of
you who decided to do that
congratulations just on your decision on
deciding to do that and for those of you
who just won't enjoyed show here red job
of played d4 and it was it was the
question where to allow whites to play D
for himself because black can start
developing for example Ruby a to grab
the B file for himself then you get d4
and the white gets what gets very easy
development you move the bishop now the
King will get into the game you'll
develop the Bush pure you'll bring the
rook back into the game and so on but a
job chooses d4 which really makes it
hard for dink to develop his pieces and
also you constantly have to be worried
about what happens if d3 if this becomes
hahaha will you develop then but okay
dingoes look the b1 and a job of castles
Queen side here so castles and this is
something that was discussed for some
reason I mean a lot of beginners the
thing that you cannot castle here
because the rook is cutting the line
between the rook and the King but that's
not the case as castling is a king's
move and the King only have to reach c8
so the King never crosses the the beef
beef out that the rook is
influencing so a castling is allowed
here of course but I will mention it
from time to time if there are some
beginners watching the videos so
castling on the other hand if the rook
was for example here or here you would
not be able to Castle queenside of
course but since the rook is here on the
B file it is allowed market a reserve of
Castle queenside and now comes Luke the
b5 activating the rook and here again
Roger bow first takes this opportunity
to bring the other look into the game
with check King to d1 biding and now
comes the best row back to b6 so what do
you do here here being again has to
decide what to do he can decide whether
to play actively and give back his extra
pawn or try to play a bit more passively
and try to keep the extra pawn basically
the pawn on f2 because once the position
opens up the bishop will go after this
this f2 pawn so one such idea is rook to
e1 which offers a trade but then we get
D captures and C three characters
capture Sonny eight and now D captures
and c3 and the bishop would pick up DF
to pawn
so here the material is equal and both
players a well equal material of Bishops
of the same color 3.0 and each it's a
pretty drone drawn in game so instead
after Bishop to b6 Dean went for C
capture son d4 right away with the ship
cab for Sundy for and now just to look
the f1 ending says okay for the moment
I'm keeping my extra pawn and depending
on how our Java plays the same game I'm
gonna try to put my pawns for example on
light squares here and get this guy here
this guy here and then claim I have a
bit of a better position with just being
up a pawn so a jumbo goes looked east
six his idea is now from rope to e6 he
can go to a six threaten some points on
the Queen side he can go to h6
threatened points on the Kings side if
you go to the King side then being will
most likely have to play something like
h4 put his pawns on dark squares which
he doesn't want to do as the rook is
pretty much stuck guarding the f2 pawn
since it didn't chose that passive line
but okay
Neen continues Bishop to b2 he decides
to trade bishops here with Bishop no we
don't have a better way of rook to a 6s
plan going after the a to pawn and now
ding Trey's
the shopkeeper son before rook captures
on d4 and now rook back to be to
guarding the a21 so here being still up
upon and he still wants to well start
activating his rook at least some way
but we have looked DJ for here reserve
of doubles up on the a file and now he's
ready to recapture his his pawn
so rook to e1 and now first King to d7
not allowing rook the rook to e8 check
so the rook can undermine the pawns on
the King set from behind so first King
to d7 and now rook to b8 dink tries to
you know infiltrate the back ranks this
way and also this rook is now coming to
eh so it could be a little bit dangerous
our job of recap versus a pawn we have
King ruck after Sonny a - and now rook
eth doubling up on the back rank but
here a job of course decides to
eliminate one of the rooks he plays rook
to e1 check King to e2 and now rook the
e6 check for single trade of rooks with
rook captures King captures and here I
think the deliverer check with rook e8
and it was in this position unmoved 28
that being in the job of agreed to a
draw so game 4 ends in the draw
it's a it's the same I mean it's an
equal position our job does have the
outside passed pawn but with dink having
two points whereas the Reserve has three
the the pawns will be easier targets for
the rook and well both of them agree
that this is a draw and of course the
engine agrees that this is a draw the
engine might give a slight advantage to
white doing his better pawn structure
but the players of course know that this
is a draw and dink is not eager to try
and over grind this as he is of course
very confident in his in his skills to
take another job of in in both the rapid
and blitz as he well he is pretty much
the only person to eliminate Magnus
Carlsen from from tiebreaks during the
sinful cup last time Magnus cross and
was the tiebreaks was some 10 years ago
it was gonna be very exciting and
tomorrow in the rapid section I'm
expecting some
crazier games these were very solid
games on both things win and their job
of the win in this match were world just
beautiful true brilliance is but those
were some heavy grinds and in the rapid
section I'm pretty sure we're gonna see
a lot more action so looking forward to
that very much but yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Stephen Midgley Jeff graves and
Michael Buckley a Brent Baxter and
crispy card for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video Sarah think all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World Cup
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course doing the
conclusion to the couple Monica saga
when this one is all of this ends so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day